par chris bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france est la haute
autorité se targue d'un bilan positif
selon son rapport annuel partagez vous
cette vision alors est-ce que je partage
cette vision c'est un peu délicat parce
que depuis ses origines la question
d'efficacité de l'hadopi a toujours été
posée il s'agit de savoir si lorsque
l'hadopi adresse un avertissement est ce
que les avertissements vont conduire
effectivement les abonnés concernés par
ces alertes qui sont quand même des
phases phase très pénales vont les
conduire vont les inciter à aller
acheter des offres légales va voir les
inciter à aller sur netflix ou spotify
j'ai toujours toujours été dubitatif là
dessus je suis pas certain que le leur
parce qu'un consommateur se retrouve
avec une espèce de deux pistolets de
menaces sur la tempe
celui ci va courir dans les boutiques à
acheter des oeuvres alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que la hadopi est maître de son de
son bilan est forcément elle va plutôt
le glorifier plutôt que de le démonter
donc il faudrait plutôt qu'on ait un
tiers qu'ils soient là pour jauger de
cette efficacité
justement le fossé entre le coût et les
résultats 82 millions d'euros à l'état
français c'est beaucoup par 82 millions
d'euros c'est beaucoup parce que c'est
beaucoup à la fois oui et non oui c'est
beaucoup en valeur absolue et non parce
que il a fallu créer une autorité de
toutes parts de toutes pièces avec ça
veut dire des locaux des infrastructures
ça veut dire aussi un système
d'information à un système informatique
qui soit capable d'adresser des millions
et des millions d'avertissement depuis
depuis les origines
ça veut dire aussi des agents
administratifs qui sont la 14e étape
dévoués à cette mission qui est prévu
par les textes donc ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix donc c'est toute une
machine qui a dû être mise en oeuvre et
dont la mission principale
ça reste quand même d'adresser ses
avertissements même si d'autres missions
sont prévues par le législateur et par
quels moyens peut-on améliorer la lutte
contre le piratage sur internet selon
vous il ya deux possibilités lorsqu'on
en phase
pédagogique comme ça soit on a une
optique j'allais dire pénale
c'est l'un des choix qui était qui a été
fait par la france en 2009 dont il
s'agit de d'adresser des menaces des
menaces pénales puisqu'au bout du cette
procédure le labo neri puisqu'une
contraventions pouvant atteindre 1500
euros donc ça c'est la première
stratégie d hab stratégie ça consiste
aussi à créer un climat ambiant qui soit
suffisamment opportuniste j'allais dire
pour créer l'éclosion d'une offre d'une
offre légale qui soit kit fois un solide
et je pense notamment à netflix je pense
notamment à à spotify qui ont créé comme
ça une offre qui a pu correspondre aux
attentes des utilisateurs d'où le succès
aussi de ses solutions
donc ces deux approches la france a opté
pour une approche pénale bon je sais pas
si c'est la bonne la bonne solution en
l'occurrence spotify et netflix ne sent
pas français mais concrètement quels
sont les risques réels pour ce qu'ils
visionnent par exemple des films sur des
sites de streaming sur le web
en pure théorie juridique
il pourrait éventuellement selon la
jurisprudence de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
être éventuellement embêté et faire
l'objet d'une possible plainte mais je
vous dis que je tiens vraiment à le
souligner que cette solution n'est pas
encore tout à fait tout à fait solide ce
qui est sûr c'est que l'émetteur le site
qui va émettre des flux en streaming des
films en streaming par exemple de
manière illicite c'est à dire sans
l'autorisation des ayants droit
lui il risque jusqu'à trois cents mille
euros d'amendé et trois ans de prison
en tout cas l'éditeur côté internautes
c'est plus délicat est ce qu'il faut
également rappeler et comme s'il a été
fait dans votre dans votre présentation
c'est que l'hadopi et toutes concentrées
sur un mode des changes qui avait un
certain succès dans les années 2000
c'est le peer to peer les échanges pair
à pair et décentralisé mais elle est
totalement incompétente juridiquement et
même techniquement sur les autres modes
de diffusion que sont le streaming et le
direct download
d'où aussi une espèce de constat d'échec
qui est qui et qui avait été souligné
dès le départ en 2009
un constat d'échec sur sur ses autres
modes et qui viennent aussi quelque part
justifié l'intervention du législateur
pour que les compétences de l'hadopi
soit étendu à ces autres à ses autres
véhicules
merci marc risque d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du site web nextel
actes
merci beaucoup